hi I'm Brianna with freako camp and
today we're going to be talking about
the binary numeral system also known as
a bunch of ones and zeros over and over
again we're going to start by labeling
starting backwards how many numbers
there are this will be 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
pretty straightforward so far the next
step that we're going to do is take two
to the power of whatever places so here
it'll be 2 to the 0 2 to the 1 - 2 - 2
to the 3 you get the picture alright now
that we've got the 2 to the given power
figured out all we got to do is fill in
some lengths and we'll have our solution
2 to the 0 is you got it 1 2 to the 1 is
2 2 to the 2 is 4 we've got 8 16 32 64
and that just keeps going on and on next
what we're going to do is seeing ok
which one's these numbers do we keep all
right so the next step figure out which
numbers do we keep do we just add all of
these together and if these were all
ones then yes we would but some of them
are zeros the zero is the same thing as
like an off switch 1 being on 0 being
off so we can go ahead and cross all of
these out right here because they're
they're not going to really matter we
want to keep this one this one here and
here because they have the corresponding
ones which means yes it's on we want to
keep that number basically from here on
out we're just going to add these 4
numbers together getting us we've got 72
there's 475 so this number in binary
means 75